[Musique]
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à ne
plus supporter les mesures sanitaires
qui depuis des mois les empêche de
travailler un ras-le-bol qui pousse
certains appellent à la désobéissance en
restant ouverts si la police décide de
m'arrêter au m'arrêteront pas s'il veut
le faire mais mon restaurant et
fermement le régime
j'ai déjà gagné parce que la population
est là tout le monde de l'art c'est le
cas notamment de stéphane turillon
restaurateurs dans le doubs qui avait
appelé le 5 janvier dernier en direct
sur notre plateau à rouvrir tous les
restaurants ouvrez ouvrez parce que
c'est le symbole et qui compte une
opération coup-de-poing qui a été tenue
aujourd'hui dans son établissement nos
caméras étaient présentes pour capter
l'instant
moi ce que je défends si ta moustache
oculaires graves
vous avez tous deux brawn est un peu
importe qui est mort coude si vous êtes
sur place pas moins de 500 personnes
journalistes clients et restaurateurs
étaient présents une grande vague de
soutien pour faire réagir le
gouvernement sans combat et d'efforts il
centre en bois et des justes on est là
pour pour se battre pour nos libertés
le plus important c'est d'être présent
pour montrer le soutien aux gens qui ont
envie de se bouger nous montrer encadré
mais qui pourrait motiver d'autres
restaurateurs à faire de même
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
a justement tenu à mettre en garde les
frondeurs ont ceux qui ne respectent pas
les règles n'auront plus de soutien de
la part de l'état alors les
restaurateurs ont-ils bien fait de se
rebeller est juste le monde à stéphane
du rayon qui étaient avec nous merci
stéphane et stéphane manigold merci
stéphane hains ça fait plaisir de vous
voir tous les deux il ya stéphane tapis
salut stéphane qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous voulez ouvrir votre établissement
ce midi mais visiblement ça ne s'est pas
fait qu'est ce qui est déjà beaucoup de
pression personnellement parce que ça
fait trois semaines que je fais un
tapage pour essayer de trouver mon resto
et alors il s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé concrètement beaucoup de monde et
vu un copte a pu le voir
alors justement on va on va revoir votre
journée puisqu'elle était assez chargé
des gens n'avaient que cette journée
était marquée par une idée stéphane
celle de la liberté forcément il a
repris la marseillaise regarde moi ce
que je défends vie se défend surtout
c'est un massage populaire vous avez
tous le drone est un peu importe quel
bord multi vous parce que c'est sous le
mont artisanat soutenir et restaurateurs
vous nous restaurateurs vietnamiens à
vous
[Musique]
voilà alors ça a démarré comme ça voilà
et finalement n'ai pas pu ouvrir
ben non parce que avant et j'avais peur
aussi pour la clientèle parce qu'ils
étaient nombreux je me suis s'ils jouent
qu'un gendarme hantée qui veut et
éventuellement voir été que sa part en
échauffourées au milieu l'avc de crainte
là j'ai des amis qui étaient autour
il avait mis les bus de crs d'un village
à côté gg haine de l'autre
c'était un peu compliqué j'avais un peu
la trouille de se rhabiller on a
beaucoup discuté avec eux stéphane hier
soir une matière laissant du cac a pris
le train il arrive à 22 heures chez moi
mais on attend steph au pont cause parce
que ça peut devenir compliqué sur les
sanctions sur six c'est pas tant la
sanction et qui me fait peur hein je ne
sais pas ça qui me fait peur il apprécie
aussi l'image de la profession et vesa
donc moi j'avais vraiment envie d'ouvrir
par contre c'est vrai qu'on était une
poignée de restaurateurs à vouloir
ouvrir très peu si on avait été
franchement si on avait été arrêté que
vous n'ayez pas été plus les clients
franchement ils étaient tous a donc
prouvé l'irak aux autres restaurants
restaurateurs personnes on a été de 181
hier soir on a passé la soirée a appelé
tous les restaurateurs avec stéphane et
finaliser les autres restaurateurs ab
vous qu on fait passage du tout parce
qu'à un moment donné lie avec la
décision qui vont prendre
on sait quand même qu'il va tomber ça
peut faire mal et puis éventuellement
ils veulent vous voulez peut-être faire
enlever les licences iv ils voulaient
enlever les droits d'exploitation c'est
à dire que six mois de mai - lavez les
sciences capte droits d'exploitation tu
vois la maison puis terminez quoi ya
plus d il ya plus d'entreprises situées
entreprises et font que moi je voulais
pas faire ça ça ne voulait pas non plus
on s'est concerté on a chanté des
chansons et bu un peu de vente ensemble
pour se détendre pour voir s'il y avait
pas mal de pression
et puis way gg abdiqué j'abdique et si
on avait dix mille restaurateurs
j'aurais tant pis j'aurais ruer dans les
brancards
mais là on était finalement lhérété 5 à
ouvrir huit heures ouvrir je fais juste
un petit mot va d'ailleurs le front
national d'accord vous n'avez rien à
[ __ ] avec nous les restaurateurs parce
que la première chose que je vais vous
dire ses quatre chats boucher elle m'a
appelé moi en premier d'accord nous on
va essayer de l'aider vous vous servez à
rien alors restez chez vous qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire il ya
casillas et cyril il ya une chose qui
est parfaitement objets que c'est pour
ça que je fais le trajet pour aller
soutenir stéphane pas pour appeler à
l'insurrection je les dis
il faut il ya des lois dans ce pays il
faut les respecter et notre collectif
qui s'appelle restons ouverts et bien si
stéphane avaient fait un autre choix que
d'ouvrir et de recevoir des clients
le 2 février il aurait été fermée
définitivement il nous c'est pas notre
combat
en revanche avec les sanctions c'était
fini well as in clients le messie la
pression est trop fort tu vois je
rajoute des drames à des situations
qu'ils assument déjà dramatique et quand
on a chanté la marseillaise c'est pas un
acte de rébellion
c'était pour dire vous les clients vous
tous vous manquez vous nous manquer
terriblement nous salariés nous manque
nos agriculteurs nos vignerons toute
cette joie de vivre toute cette liberté
vous nous manquez et sans vous en fait
on est rien et il y avait beaucoup de
clients et je voulais que stéphane qui
est un super chef on a mais vraiment
très bien manger je voulais qu'ils
puissent continuer à ouvrir demain quand
les règles seront là et quand je vois
fleurance philippot qui va dans un
restaurant
katia pauvre fille qui est complètement
déprimée restauratrice et qui se
retrouvent dans son restaurant à faire
sa promo mais mec sans le chéquier et
maintenant parce que tu l'a condamné
sept filles et les responsables ce type
là alors oui effectivement tous ces gens
de cette ville à même d'aller chez katia
il a mangé chez katusha aujourd'hui
évidemment moi j'ai eu 4 au téléphone a
donc atteint me dit j'ai vendu ma
bagnole j'ai vendu ses bonnes blagues
j'ai rendu ma bagnole
j'ai vendu mes meubles j'ai deux boulots
elle travaille la nuit elle travaille un
peu le jour pour payer parce que ça ne
va pas au niveau on avait parlé des
structures comme la mienne qui n'ont pas
pu rentrer l'ipo est allé là bas pour se
guérir et derrière ça a été une
catastrophe mais si tu veux cyril tous
ces gens qui disent ouvrez ouvrez alizés
qui veulent affronter en fait sur le
terrain politique
le gouvernement nous ont fait pas de
politique on aime les gens on a juste
envie de travailler points
et ce combat politique les mecs en fait
ce qui vous si vous voulez philippot
s'il avait une paire 1
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait et fait de la
sous location à cette pauvre
restauratrice illus ou sans restaurant
et lui prend la responsabilité de mettre
son lui pénalement et pas brandir comme
ça c'est j'ai parlé des business mains
de la misère ces gens là ce sont des
business made de la misère est ce qu'il
a fait là c'est abject
nous on a passé la nuit avec stéphane à
convaincre tous les restaurateurs de ne
pas se sacrifier sur l'autel de ne pas
appeler à l'insurrection parce qu'on est
dans le dialogue et ça avance et encore
des choses qui doivent être réglés
concernant notamment les saisonniers on
a regardé les comptes hier sorte de
stéphane on n'a pas dormi de la nuit on
n'a pas dormi de la nuit
parce que on aime on et confraternelle
merci à la et on se soutient
et merci à vous de nous donner cette la
parole ça c'est merci parce que je sais
que tu as à nos côtés bah oui mais
qu'est ce que vous nous manquez tous les
clients merci mme c'est un truc de fou
non mais sérieusement et cette colère là
je lui disais de toi je parle plus
calmement parce que les auditeurs de des
pmp devait baisser le volume a écoulé 11
ans on tente en tout cas et tu peux a
parlé comme tu veux montrer mais mais
mais c'est de colère emmanuel macron
faut qu'il intègre à new york les
terrasses sont ouvertes à la triche et
lui il a la possibilité d'ouvrir la sur
l'air 69 habitants dans son village
moi j'y étais il a une terrasse qui fait
quoi 500 m² 400 800 m² tu peux avoir des
jauges à 8 mètres carrés par personne et
je prends une vmc de 500 mètres cubes
seconde parce qu on à l'époque on
faisait ce qu'on appelle des fondus
hached dont elle avait investi un gros
dodo mcg mama même s'ils fonctionnent
mieux que celle du tgv mcc c'est aussi
un gros un gros moteur je fais pas ça
moi sommes empêchés de travailler
ok j'ai essayé d'aller à la guerre avec
mes moyens à moi ok d'accord j'ai
fédérer pour oeuvrer la clientèle merci
franchement merci mais mais la tuerie
rien à dire comprendre aussi d'autres
restaurateurs qui veulent pas se mettre
en danger aussi il faut s'y mettre le
poing sur la table
aller au dialogue après j'essaie de
revenir au dialogue un gérant voix j'ai
rencontré le préfet de la région on a eu
des discussions voilà on a essayé par
contre et je le redis encore une fois
l'umih vous étiez ou d'accords sont
toujours pas là ils sont pas d'accord
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord parce que
nous aujourd'hui on est là stéphanie là
stéphane c'est pas le mien ses fans
mallégol ni restaurateur il est comme
moi d'accord il a ouvert un collectif
reste le mec il a pris le train non mais
sans déconner qui aurait fait ça tu
l'aurais fait toi le mec il a pris le
train important
leurs effets mais j'ai pris trop et tu
vas pas me lâcher
l'umih toile après un numéro 6 v/m c'est
bon ça c'est pour les uns pas vu la main
les a pas vus est lui parti c'est pas le
patron de l'irs il est descendu
il est venu avec paris passe à vis
d'elle et je n'ai pas qui je voudrais
bien je suis passé voir a créé alors ça
fait sacrifier sur l'oml politique des
combats qui nous concerne pas donc
qu'ils le gardent leur combat guillaume
il a des infos plus on regarde tout
alors bruno le maire parlait des aides
de l'état et ça va beaucoup de gens qui
n'aiment pas des aides de l'état
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent ça va
aller restaurateurs ils ont dix mille
euros par mois et c'est donc moi j'ai
enquêté j'ai appelé une dizaine de
restaurants en france et je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'une telle hargne euros par
mois aujourd'hui donc regarder je vous
ai sorti tous les chiffres allaient
donne un restaurateur aujourd'hui il à
2500 euros de loyer en corse et dans une
grande ville de province pas à paris 500
euros de charges 4000 euros de matières
premières 2000 euros par mois pour trois
salariés qui font la plonge parce qu'il
faut évidemment la vente à apporter donc
9960 au hacker charles et ils sont 400
l'air pour le gérant donc 17000 euros de
frais ça c'est un vrai restaurant que
j'ai appelé un les recettes environ 7000
euros de vente à emporter
fossard clé plate forme de livraison
elle prenne 35% en moyenne donc c'est
énorme et les fameuses aides de l'état
10000euros encore c'est le maximum 14
mille euros de recettes donc résultat
vous perdez 3000 euros par mois et
encore le gérant ne se paye pas gentil
parce qu'on a fait les chiffres avec
stéphane c'est un peu plus d'ailleurs on
n'est pas dans une nation et des loyers
j'ai pas possible c'est pas possible on
peut pas faire parce que dans la tête
des gens et les gens se disent dix mille
euros c'est énorme en fait ça paye même
pas si ça c'est pas assez dit
effectivement il ya des ajustements qui
sont à faire et moi je le dis à tous les
chefs d'entreprise les restaurateurs ce
que nous le collectif aux tons vert ben
c'est tout le monde sait les théâtres
les loisirs
car susan en général on est censé les
artisans et également les indépendants
qui sont aujourd'hui massacraient les
extraits on a réussi à dialoguer obtenir
alors 100 euros est saisonnière cela
qu'eric vous avez ouvrir malgré les
menaces ont été bien moi j'étais prêt
franchement j'étais pas à ouvrir
jusqu'au bout pourquoi parce que je
voulais vraiment défendre mon droit
travail et de liberté si stéphane
n'avait pas été là honnêtement prache
sais pas si j'aurai vraiment nettement
mai
voilà on n'a pas dormi j'avais peur de
ça je m'étais dit imagine qu'avec se
fasse baisser par un gendarme parce que
déjà on la remercie gendarmes ordinaire
et extraordinaire les attentes cabinet
du préfet d'été zhang dialogue il était
quand même en été il y avait qu à lui
j'ai dit était garée pas très loin faut
le dire
donc les mais qu'ils en gagnent venu en
mode et puis quand on a ouvert le
dialogue
en fait tout s'est très bien passé mais
c'est beaucoup ce qu'elle soit blessée
adil hermach et sauvage on veut juste
travailler et ça s'est bien passé
ouais c c'est la démonstration type qu'
il faut absolument que les régions
aujourd'hui soit responsable et elles le
sont elles demandent que ça auprès des
ja de pouvoir décider d'une ouverture
une fermeture le nombre de même les
maires de commerçants le nombre de
restaurateurs qui ont investi des
milliers d'euros pour ça ne serait-ce
vision même serait ce que pour faire
quoi pour ouvrir deux mois et on ferme
boutique derrière sûr ils sont à
l'agonie et le plus dégueulasse
franchement parce que humainement fabre
je trouve ça gerber je les ai vus dans
ton émission venir dire qu'il allait
ouvrir
il ya un côté révolte qui à côté j'en
peux plus là et ce qui leur donne là les
20% du chiffre d'affaires parce que
c'est pas dix mille euros c'est 20% du
chiffre d'affaires ou 10000 euros ou dix
mille euros c'est hyper d'exploitation
si bien c'est bien ok je sors ce que le
cayor s'il ya un tarif y ait plus de
naissances que le battant même tu vas la
radio et unis atteint science city où je
les enlève
c'est bruno losito relève la licence iv
et fêter ce matin c'était la deuxième
radio c'est minable
c'est le message par les préfets par là
par les régions ou pas tu appelles ça
une effet des messages disant tu tu as
donc vous considérez-vous restaurateurs
moi j'adore les restaurants à chalabre
et d'aller au restaurant tous les jours
donc déjà vous considérez qu'il ya aucun
risque aujourd'hui à ouvrir à ses rangs
après étude après étude a mis d'accord
ok mais vous n'êtes pas médecin moi non
plus aubin et qui fascine actuelles font
qu'un truc quand même insultant moi
j'entends parler des restaurateurs que
j'adore tout le temps il ya les chefs
d'entreprise qui rament ya les étudiants
abordent bien on en parle à chaque fois
on en parle à gérer je veux dire
aujourd'hui en a chaque fois avec une
crise sans précédent a parlé mais je
vous entends mais on est solides raconte
personnes dans un restaurant c'est gad
elmaleh qui avait raison pourquoi on
laisse passer départir des gens les
avions qui enlève le masque pour bouffer
je suis totalement d'accord avec lui
c'est ça n'a cessé la solution new york
les terrasses wada solution la solution
à toi c'est quoi hélas la solde a pas de
solution la voiture mais endémie et pour
la fin de saison délicat il faut que ce
soit un confinement total mais c'est ce
que je pense
il sait ce que j'entendais profession et
les médecins du politique moi j'ai une
question très précise pour vous stéphane
thirion oui monsieur j'avais annoncé
vraiment avec tout mon respect vous avez
annoncé vraiment très fort je veux
ouvrir de sueur aujourd'hui vous n'avez
pas ouvert vous venez d'en expliquer
pourquoi selon nos informations en fin
de semaine dernière vous avez rencontré
le préfet donc ma question très plaisir
ces objets est ce que vous avez eu des
menaces
vous êtes vous avez parlé de pressions
est ce que vous avez eu de vraie menace
pour votre restaurant et pour vous qui
vous ont conduit finalement à reculer
non j'ai pas une menace de l'état
d'accord c'est derrière l'état enfin la
jurisprudence n'est pas là juste pour
moi il est temps d'agir actions iliad il
m'a dit attention on avait discuté que
le dircab on était allé là bas mais il
dit ok je vous explique un mois champéry
l'état est juge et partie et la juge est
pas la pierre il m'a dit au pire des cas
vous risquez bien de la prison de pertes
et d'avoir des pertes financières bien
sûr et ça ils l'avaient déjà dans les
tuyaux
après et un rapport sur la licence iv
n'oublie pas parce que là ils sont ce qu
a dit qu'on doit avoir un casier vierge
au cas où il ya aussi au niveau du droit
d'exploitation parce que si on parlait
des permis d'exploitation jamais vous
venez pas ce qu il appelait même moi je
suis témoin d'une situation le directeur
de cabinet du préfet il a donné son
numéro de portable et il a ouvert la
main il a dit discutons parce
qu'effectivement la situation allait
compliquer le dialogue m'a demandé de
participer à des réunions pour aider les
restaurateurs du doubs apporter des
solutions et gym avec plaisir donc ils
sont le dialogue est là
locale en fait c'est juste les faits
exactement localisés sur un local
on va faire une demande au niveau de
l'état avec quand les informations que
vous avez ou courir ouvriront pour
l'instant la date derrière fictive celle
ci les joueurs s'ils avaient joué les
gens à bavans alors après il y aura les
terrasses nous mais ça fait quelle
température à marseille puis 18 degrés
20 degrés dimanche sur le trottoir
bernard martin est venu de le faire en
deux temps d'abord les terrasses ou
après les restaurants bars comme
benchmark les téléspectateurs oui à 61 %
à 8 9 39% voyez il était spectateur
parce que vous avez raison de vous
rebeller en tout cas merci d'abord est
avec nous on voulait faire un point avec
vous puisque c'était le fameux jour
aujourd'hui 1er février finale victoire
n'avait pas ouvert de mai à ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que si on a ouvert
quand même qu on a mangé et on a donné
on a donné faut pas oublier on n'a pas
fait j'ai rien fait payer on a tout
donné aux restos du coeur
grosse cagnotte
[Applaudissements]